Steffen Henssler ihr liebt ihn das merke
ich jedes Mal wenn ich ein Video mit
Sachen von ihm mache und ich kann gut
verstehen warum der Typ hat es einfach
drauf und er hat ein Weihnachtsmenü
gemacht welches man als kochbox
bestellen kann genau das habe ich getan
und wir wollen uns heute gemeinsam
ausprobieren es ist wieder von euch
haben gesagt dass das letzte Menü mit 49
€ etwas teuer war dieses Menü hier
kostet 120 € für zwei Personen deshalb
könnte ich mir vorstellen dass es für
viele sehr sehr teuer ist ich möchte den
ganzen erstmal eine Chance geben und
sagen okay lohnt sich das oder zahlt man
vielleicht viel für den Namen wir haben
drei Gerichte man sieht natürlich auch
von wem das ganze kommt Steffen Henssler
eine Süßkartoffel Chili Suppe ist unsere
Vorspeise welche schon in einem
praktischen Beutel vor uns liegt dann
der Hauptgang eine Oldenburger Ente mit
Rotkohl und Klößen und das Dessert ein
Macadamia Brownie mit Vanillesoße und
bärengrütze also sehr weihnachtlich ist
es auf jeden Fall ich bin gespannt was
wir wirklich jetzt bekommen werden und
ob es einem voran den hohen Anspruch
oder den hohen Standard den ich von
Steffen Henssler gewohnt bin
entsprechend wird ich bin gespannt
fangen wir an mit der Vorspeise besteht
daraus dass ich diese Suppe hier
aufwärme
[Musik]
3 Liter Wasser sind aufgekocht das heißt
machst du jetzt direkt wieder aus und
gebe jetzt diesen Beutel hinein für 15
Minuten jetzt müssen wir nur noch warten
bis es einmal warm geworden ist dann
portioniere ich das Ganze und das ist
alles was wir für die Vorspeise machen
müssen eigentlich gar nichts so ich habe
zum Glück in Date Gas mit dem ich das
ganze jetzt verköstigen darf denn wir
haben ja ein Menü für zwei Personen
gemacht Leute das stimmt wirklich ja du
bist schon du bist so in Weihnachten
Spinner ihr könnt gerne meine Kommentare
schreiben ob ich vielleicht auch mal
meinen weihnachtsstimme für dieses Jahr
auf dem Kanal angezeigt soll ja ich bin
nämlich gerade was am Plan ich mache
nämlich meine Eltern sind ja getrennt ne
ja jedes zweite Jahr bin ich bei meinem
Dad und erreiche mich immer die Ehre das
Weihnachtsmenü zubereiten deshalb plane
ich gerade wenn ihr das sehen wollt
könnt ihr mal in die Kommis schreiben
also das hier ist unsere Vorspeise etwas
außerordentlich es riecht aber fast also
es riecht fantastisch
wir haben die Süßkartoffelsuppe Wahnsinn
aber es riecht wirklich sehr sehr gut
probieren wir mal ich habe nämlich ein
bisschen die Befürchtung dass das ganze
nicht alles zu Weihnachten könnte
ein Aspekt ist krass ich habe es
vielleicht gehört wie knusprig und
knackig das Gemüse noch ist ne das krass
ja das ist so Loki gar nicht da drin
gekocht worden bestimmt die Karotte ist
komplett knapp frisch obwohl die auch
die ganze Zeit in dieser Flüssigkeit war
das heißt es kann ja gar nicht so lange
da drin gewesen sein ja so sieht das
halt auf dem Foto aus
aber auch perfekt aussehen halt auch ob
die so aussehen
aber ich bin auch gespannt 129 € alt
heute ne teurer Spaß wenn du jetzt sagen
würdest ich nehme heute mal meine
Freundin reservieren den Tisch beim
Hamster drei Gänge Menü würdest du auch
nicht damit rechnen weniger als 130 € zu
bezahlen definitiv nicht entscheiden
Namen natürlich auch also man kann nicht
sagen außer dass die Suppe wirklich sehr
sehr lecker ist oder wobei man sagen
muss jetzt in einem Weihnachtsmenü wenn
ich jetzt die Augen zu mache und mir ein
Weihnachtsmenü vorstelle dann ist jetzt
nicht direkt so eine Süßkartoffel
chilisuppe von meinen Augen
klassischen Weihnachten das macht mich
9.10
beim Hauptgang wird vielleicht anders
ihr habt ja schon gesehen das geben
könnte viel Spaß bei der Zubereitung da
bin ich sehr gespannt so eine Ente muss
man auch erstmal hinbekommen ja das war
schon mal nicht schlecht aber eine Sache
ihr habt es gehört hat mir vielleicht
ein bisschen gefehlt dieses klassische
Weihnachtsgefühl so anders sieht's aus
bei Geflügel klar die Weihnachtsgans
kennt glaube ich jeder die Weihnachts
Ente ist auch im kommen habe ich mir
sagen lassen und die haben jetzt auch
beim Hauptgericht das ist was wir vor
uns haben wir sehen direkt es sind
wesentlich mehr Zutaten was ich auch
irgendwo gut finde weil so dieser eine
Beutel das war irgendwie so dann hat man
sich nicht gefühlt als würde man auch
etwas tun diesmal tun wir ein bisschen
was das hier ist der Star der Show eine
Ente eine Oldenburger Ente mit der
irgendwas geschehen ist ich glaube die
wurde in irgendeiner Form vorgegebener
ist auf jeden Fall schon ein bisschen
Farbe dran und wie die das gemacht haben
ob die die unter einem broiler irgendwie
einmal angegrillt haben ich weiß es
nicht genau aber es muss so was reverse
ciamäßiges sein denn sie kommt für 60
Minuten bei 200 Grad in den Ofen ich
weiß nicht was das mit euch macht aber
mich stimmt das ein bisschen kritisch
wir gucken uns das ganze einfach mal an
das einzige was da steht Brust nach oben
das machen wir jetzt dann haben für die
anderen Sachen auf jeden Fall genug Zeit
aber ab in den Ofen 60 Minuten Timer und
dann geht's weiter mit den Beilagen
[Musik]
okay das ist wirklich interessant Leute
wir sind etwa wenn es hochkommt ich habe
den Timer nicht direkt gestartet sind
wir vielleicht 25 Minuten im Ofen wir
haben schon 56 Grad Kerntemperatur wenn
man meinem fancy Thermometer Glauben
schenken kann und mein Ofen sagt sogar
es dauert nur noch 3 Minuten bis sie bei
63 Grad Kerntemperatur ist das wäre die
Hälfte der Zeit aber ich kann es mir
eigentlich nicht vorstellen sollen wir
mal das Thermostat woanders reinstecken
vom testen einmal um ob das vielleicht
unser Fehler war jetzt so sind wir
direkt unten am Brustbein schauen wir
mal vielleicht was hier oben ist dieses
Kerntemperatur Messgerät ist immer so
ein bisschen
Ofen man fragt so wie soll das
funktionieren weil das Kabel wird der
heißt aber es wird schon irgendwie
funktioniert was auch funktionieren
sollte ist dass wir unsere Vakuumbeutel
mit der enden und unser Rotkohl
gemeinsam warm machen können hier drüben
geht's weiter mit unserem Kloßteig den
achteln wir jetzt einmal
wir haben perfekte Achtel die keineswegs
unterschiedlich groß sind wir nehmen uns
unsere Klöße Formen die einmal mit dem
Handballen aus zwei Croutons hat auf
jeden Fall dadurch so ein bisschen
diesen selfmade Look das sieht sehr sehr
schön aus mit diesen dampfenden
Kochtöpfen sieht auch sehr weihnachtlich
aus ja
mal fertig
es könnte kaum einfacher sein
man ist sich jetzt gerade so echt
unsicher oder also wir haben
nachgeschaut Kerntemperatur im Schenkel
beträgt sogar 80 Grad das wir ziehen das
jetzt raus ich habe vielleicht 40
Minuten das ganze drin gehabt aber auf
jeden Fall keine Stunde
[Musik]
testen ich muss gleich
wir haben ein paar schöne Stücke jetzt
geht's ans Probieren was ist dein erster
Eindruck Ersteindruck ist das Digue
extrem nach irgendetwas riecht so zimtig
ein bisschen vielleicht Marone ja ich
finde es richtig richtig
ne musst du mal die Stücke ohne Haut
probieren das ist super gut wieder ne ne
das sind halt so Sachen wie kriegt man
also als Normalsterblicher schon gar
nicht beim ersten Mal immer richtig
richtig gut hin so Soßen sind halt
einfach durch die große Kunst ich würde
jetzt auch gar nicht wie ich die Soße
mache
was man sagen muss wir haben keine
perfekte rosa Farbe also das ist jetzt
so würde man wahrscheinlich nicht im
Restaurant bekommen so hier kann mehr
schief gehen Erwartungen ja genau
das Herz vom Gericht das muss krass sein
und das ist richtig lecker aber nicht so
mein blowing Größe sind geil und das
finde ich gar nichts sagen so richtig
schön so klebrige Klöße bist welche
Punktzahl gibt du also alles was wir
gesagt haben
also sowas im Restaurant
gar nichts eigentlich so ne aber wir
haben natürlich zu Recht sehr hohe
Erwartungen auch Preis so deshalb ich
will acht von zehn trotzdem geben ja es
fehlt einfach so ein bisschen was so
weißt du aber acht von zehn würde ich
sagen glaube das ist auch so weil es so
einfach für uns war das zu machen hat
man auch kennst du manchmal machst du
sowas übelst lange und dann bist du so
groß und dann ist auch noch wenigstens
diese Arbeit jetzt dahinter gewesen und
deswegen ist es dann trotzdem eine neuen
von 10 für dich schauen wir mal nachher
als Dessert haben wir Macadamia Brownies
mit Vanillesoße und bärengrütze die
sollten wir einfach nur warm machen für
5 Minuten 160 Grad genau das haben wir
getan fertig ja also das 100 %. ja die
werden die halt fertig gebacken haben
aber sonst fertigen Brownie zu sehen das
hat irgendwie sowas von Backwerk finde
ich so zumindest so einen Charakter ja
letztes Gericht ja also es ist wirklich
irgendwo zwischen essen gehen essen
bestellen und selbst kochen weil man ist
nicht so angestrengt oder so das ist
einfach schon eine echt entspannte
Angelegenheit gerade hier Ding in den
Ofen geschoben die beiden anderen Sachen
dazu gesch fertig optisch
eine optisch finde ich ehrlich gesagt
fertiger Brownie halt ne vielleicht
überrascht uns ja die Konsistenz richtig
ja wow das scheint so richtig weich ja
der ist innen drin übertrieben weich das
hätte ich schon mal nicht gedacht ab in
die Vanille Songs
[Musik]
der verklebt einem so den Mund vor
lauter Schokolade schmeckt auf jeden
Fall noch mehr aussieht viel mehr ja
also jetzt merkt man auch den Kranken
Unterschied zu Backwerk und das nehmen
wir ein bisschen großes Stück Sorge weil
ich dachte mir so alter so wenn das
jetzt so Stani Ding ist oder dann ist
das ja schon fast so ein bisschen übel
mitgespielt ja ja aber der ist echt
krank außen hier diese Oberschicht ne
die ist ja so übel ja und da drunter ist
der das klingt immer gefühlt immer alles
aus dem knusprig in fluffig ne aber das
ist jetzt innen nicht fluffig das falsch
das Bild hier spricht jetzt für sich das
so saftig Essen hast ja der ist nass
aber so geil ja halt saftige dadurch ja
also hat auf jeden Fall nichts von so
einem fertig Brownies kennst du so
manchmal sagt man bei so einem Dessert
das ist sehr lecker das auch nicht so
süß ja das sagt man hier nicht auf jeden
Fall sehr süß sehr sehr süß sehr üppig
so wie man Zeit bei dem Weihnachtsessen
aber auch will also das ist so ein
richtiges okay jetzt noch schnell
Geschenke auspacken und dann zwei
Stunden auf Couch liegen wir hatten so
eine kleine Erwartungshaltung weil wir
dachten so Backwerk fertig Burger aber
der hat uns jetzt überzeugt das ist echt
verrückt bin ich satt bin ich happy nach
dem Menü ja hat es Spaß gemacht das mit
diesem mit den Anweisungen zu kochen war
es entspannt was convenient für mich
nicht einkaufen zu müssen ja safe wie
große Sache die natürlich über den
ganzen Schwert sind 130 € 129 € für die
Box für zwei Personen das ist viel Geld
finde ich so ihr habt beim letzten Mal
wie gesagt schon Kritik geäußert bei der
49 € Box für zwei Person ich darauf auch
ein bisschen eingehen und ich muss sagen
ich glaube vor allem Fans von Steffen
Henssler kommen ja auf ihre Kosten es
gibt viele
Sachen aber die kommen auf ihre Kosten
sowieso merch-artikel also weißt du
schon du gibst ja auch gerne 10 € mehr
für einen T-Shirt von deiner
Lieblingsband oder dein lieblings
Youtuber aus weil du halt supporten
willst und so ist das auch ein Premium
Produkt wo man safe auch den Namen mit
bezahlt ich habe im letzten Video schon
einen Link für euch passiert ist immer
noch aktiv also falls ihr euch damit
kochbox bestellen wollt geht über meinen
Link oder benutzt den Code max dann
spart ihr mal 15 Prozent ich hoffe ihr
wisst auch nach dem heutigen Video dass
ich nicht gekauft bin sondern dass sie
einfach nur eine Partnerschaft mit denen
habe weil ich kann auch kritisch darüber
äußern beim letzten Mal Fall ist halt
wirklich geil und gutes Baby danke dass
ihr zugeschaut habt danke dass du da
warst wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video
wieder und bis dahin macht's gut ciao
ciao wenn Eric Weg ist seht ihr hier
drüben und für euch vorgeschlagenes
Video darunter könnt ihr den Kanal
abonnieren tut es bitte sonst werde ich
weinen und bis zum nächsten Mal ciao